I like the feeling of like if you're in
war with them and you know he's on the
other side of the wall they just stick a
Playboy around the corner and just here
[Laughter]
those are the ninja stars
[Music]
all right we got some news from
Indonesia oh yeah there is a new law
that is making it illegal to have sex
outside of marriage
[Laughter]
it's crazy what are they gonna do in
Bali that's all people do
people there's so many foreigners in
Bali I feel like Bali though they go and
they're tourists let them do whatever
they want so there's a little bit of a
loophole with that is they're not it
this is gonna be the law but in Bali for
tourists they're just not gonna check
that's what I thought they're not gonna
check your marital status because like
there's also homosexuality in Bali and
all that like there's gay couples
whatever right around Indonesia they be
doing that crazy [__] where like they're
like the the honor killing stuff and all
that stuff because they're like the
honor coming stuff no we we did JK news
about like Indonesian couples getting
caught being gay and stuff and then like
they're just like
um you know the village are just like
hurting them oh god well let me ask you
this how would they like aside from the
Taurus how do they even check up on
people if they're [__] or not duh
they got gaydar number one wait we're
talking about just marriages
there aren't hotels like just seeing if
two people are checking into a hotel
that's how I remembered it being in a
your last name not the same
yeah like that they yell at you so so
somebody can't stop and visit a friend
at a hotel right
why are you not married maybe it's like
no visitors after a certain time if
you're not they do that in Vietnam dude
so daytime sex okay oh it's keeping the
prostitutes out yep oh yeah they're like
if you have someone that you would like
to add on our list it has to be before
like 7 P.M so they're just letting me
know if you want a hooker make sure you
put her on the list before 7 pm and you
guys could come in that's tight that's
great I remember when I was in China the
the hookers were just in the lobby of
the hotel just chilling if you wanted a
hooker you literally on your way to your
room you are wild why you see that [__]
too don't bring mean to your story I
didn't do that how do you know that did
I have a name tag it just says hooker no
they have like a neon sign he was also
staying at the at the red light district
Hotel
it was just it was just a shag guy
because because the the guides told us
that those are hookers and then they
we're just straight up look like it's
pretty obvious when you see it though
like in China they're just everywhere
they're just trying to make eye contact
with you you know what I mean like
they're always trying to catch your eyes
and you're like why is this nine giving
me this attention like I'm a 10. I think
I have a shot with her you're like
you're a hooker no way yeah that you
never saw that and go to any hotel in
China did you ever notice that yeah I
noticed it
so the thing is it's not only sex
outside of marriage it's also cohabiting
that's kind of like it's it's all in one
so it's like I think kind of that's how
you can also dang you got to be married
so you can't even like live in sin as
they say yeah but what if you're just
roommates you can't do it what sprouted
this whole thing do they have a were
they dealing with the problem it's
because of the the Muslim population you
know how like as the the laws from that
religion kind of bleed into the
government all like Sharia law or
whatever kind of like that yeah it's
moving more towards that direction
interesting so they're getting more
conservative exactly whoa that's kind of
great so what's the punishment if they
catch you death I don't know
we were in Malaysia they told us that
there's like a Muslim police that
um
so like you know when there's like
Ramadan and [__] right there you can't
be like drinking and clubbing and stuff
and then they would come into the clubs
and then they would check the IDS of
Malay kids they didn't give a [__] about
like white kids Chinese kids they don't
give a [__] they're like you guys could
violate Ramadan all you want because
that's on you to go to hell right but
they would they would be like a Sharia
law police is that like the morality
police for Iran I don't know if it's the
same thing but like they would go in and
they'd be like oh you [__] up and then
they would have a different set of rules
for the Malay kids oh just to see if
they were like locals if they were the
Muslim kids yeah yeah dangerous yeah so
they had their own security it was
different how they know they were
Muslims from the IDS though because most
of the uh Malik ethnic groups are Muslim
I see I see just by default and in the
Chinese in Malaysia
typically aren't I see what if it says
it on their ID wouldn't that be crazy
yeah right Muslim or Chinese yeah
yeah wow that was weird I was like damn
how you gonna have more rules when this
is your country
man you know what you give the other
citizens more rules and you do all the
free [__] what if they have like you
know now that premarital sex is outlawed
they got like sex speakeasies and [__]
that's probably gonna happen you gotta
sneak around to a sex club if you want
to get down and then there's sex bust
yeah
oh yeah sex sting one of the main why
don't you just get married real quick
that's true the divorce right after
because people be like I would be like I
would be like Las Vegas where I'm like
that's probably why Las Vegas you have
the shotgun weddings and [__] because
back then America was more conservative
and they're like you're not having
prematural sex are you right you just
[__] real quick because you're married
and then you get a divorce you go to
make a good Christian woman over yeah
yeah right as if God is up there like
they about to [__] they're going to hell
oh you went to Vegas real quick do your
thing guys be good now oh man they got
divorced that's too bad rules the rules
man yeah like God cares about cares
about the rules and the technicalities
exactly oh okay okay
it was just a giant spike in cyber sex
and phone sex and uh Indonesia from now
on oh I don't know it's not I don't know
if they're getting hornier because of
this but one thing is for certain is
one way to think I'm down with religion
people get so horny your parents your
parents can complain about like a
relationship you have it's more like you
get ratted out easier
now there's grounds for your parents to
rat you out because your parents are
like man I don't want you [__] that
guy yeah so it's it's a good parental
assist in a way this law because they're
like I don't like that she's spending
too much time with this guy they're
probably [__] does it say what the
punishment is let's see because if it's
like a ticket then imagine it's a point
where only the rich kids are the ones
[__] like the rich people are like oh
I can pay the 500 take it let's [__]
yeah yeah yeah but it's a point on your
record so you got to go to Driving
School oh my God [__] school
[__] school that's hilarious a lot of
[__] school you didn't [__] properly
it might just be jail
well you won't be
some G's in jail that are just like I'm
here all the time I'll be [__] yeah
what are you in for [__]
for time this week holy [__] [__]
just tallying on his arms with scars
Girl Buddy he hasn't married her yet so
he's multiple violations because he
[__] his girlfriend multiple times
every time he comes in he says what's up
to the [__] staff though what's up
George yeah I'm back and the [__] the
main the main dude like the boss of the
jail like the main guy he's like damn
all I did was kill somebody
[Laughter]
virgin murderer he's been in there for
life and he's just mad just like as if
[__] new social medias rolling around
with the young kids he's like man it's
all different now so you know what's
crazy so like like the level of um sin
or like how bad stuff is it it changes
depending on culture right so my buddy
is
um out there in Afghanistan right now
going to theme parks with the Taliban
and all that [__] he's sending me photos
it's [__] it's wild right it's a trip
he travels the world going to like
really difficult
um places for journalists to go to and
then he just wants to do art like he
makes friends with Headhunters tribes
all that stuff and he'll put like
watches and like all this stuff on them
and then like do high fashion photo
shoots with them yeah and so he has got
he has some stuff with the Taliban and
what he told me was when their uh CIA
version like their secret police guys
caught him interrogated him they were
looking at his like photos on the phone
and they were getting grossed out by his
like [__] shots on girls and like all
this they're just like oh oh right and
then later they became friends they all
became friends right and then so what
but they don't but what they'll do is
they share photos of guys that they
torture of other guys that they capture
beheadings and [__] yeah and then for
them they're trading this [__] around
like it's all good like it's news
they're just like they're just like
they're just like oh this is [__]
these guys are the [__] enemy we got
these guys we kidnapped them must be
crazy yeah it's like grabbing the head
like yeah so that [__] is normal that
[__] is like hey look at what I did the
guys we beat this guy up right and then
but then when when they went through his
photos and and then they saw him like
having a threesome and like all these
they're just like
bro you need to tell me trigger warning
it's like this like those cats when you
make them sniff cheese
he was like it was the wildest thing
because like trigger warning I'm gonna
lose my lunch it's it's
crazy
he has to look at him beheading to feel
better he's like oh God
because for them what they're doing is
they're they're killing bad guys in
their heads they're doing they're
they're doing the good thing right but
then also sex and all that stuff is like
it's bad like that's not Kosher sex it's
like it's like you're also like looking
at all these oh my God you're [__]
horrible people because you're defiling
your mind by looking yeah the top down
look at this is like he's one of us
dude that's I like the feeling of like
if you're in war with them and you know
he's on the other side of the wall and
you just stick a Playboy around the
corner and just here
[Laughter]
those are the ninja stars
at night they're just [__] putting
projector on their buildings and turning
up the volume like Sonic torture
you just hear a bunch of gagging
that's crazy I know right yeah dude who
wouldn't know that's their weakness this
whole time it's [__] wild dude yeah
man so it does say up to a year in jail
for if you're unmarried and you're
having sex or if you're just cohabiting
and you're not having sex you get six
months in jail that's tough bro yeah so
it's serious man and again it doesn't
apply to tourists or uh anyone in Bali I
think if you're like a bali tourist they
don't they just don't check that's got
to be so obnoxious I know oh my God like
tourists come mine just [__]
everywhere and you're just they're like
man what if a tourist has sex with a
local
laughs
[Laughter]
[Music]